PRESIDENT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT ASSOCIATE IN AN
MARK STEYN TO DISCUSS WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT IT MEANS.
BUT FIRST, OVER THE PAST MONTH,
A CARAVAN OF CENTRAL AMERICAN
MIGRANTS HAS GRADUALLY MADE IT
UP TO HONDURAS TO MEXICO ALL THE
WAY TO TIJUANA, OPPOSITE
SAN DIEGO.
AT ONE POINT MAKE SKIN
AUTHORITIES CLAIM THEY BROKE UP
AND AMERICAN MEDIA DUTIFULLY
REPORTED THEY DID.
THEY DIDN'T.
THAT WAS A P.R. GESTURE AND A
TEMPORARY ONE.
IN FACT, DURING PART OF THE
TRIP, MEXICAN POLICE ESCORTED
THE MIGRANTS NORTHWARD.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MEXICAN
MIGRANTS ABETTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION INTO THIS COUNTRY AS
IT'S DONE FOR MANY YEARS.
TONIGHT, THE CARAVAN IS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
RATHER THAN WAIT FOR THE
CROSSING STATION TO OPEN, MANY
OF THEM JUMPED THE FENCE.
SOME WAVED HONDURAN FLAGS WHEN
THEY GOT TO THE TOP.
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
WHEN YOU ARRIVE IN A COUNTRY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO IT AND ASSIMILATE
INTO ITS CULTURE, DON'T WAVE THE
FLAG OF A FOREIGN NATION.
THAT'S WHEN YOU DO IN TRIUMPH
WHEN YOU INVADE A COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO BORDER CONTROL, AT
LEAST ONE MEMBER OF THE CARAVAN
HAS A READY ADMITTED TO BEING A
MEMBER OF MS-13.
ALL OF THAT SHOULD WORRY US.
THERE'S ONLY A FEW HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN THIS CARAVAN, BUT
THERE ARE BILLIONS MORE AROUND
THE WORLD WHO LIVED AMID
VIOLENCE AND POVERTY IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM WOULD LIKE TO RELOCATE TO
SAN DIEGO.
THE LEFT ARGUES WE HAVE NO MORAL
RIGHT TO STOP ANY OF THEM FROM
DOING THAT.
HERE IS TURNING TO A NICKEL
RAMUS OF TIJUANA DANCING THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT AS CRIMINAL FOR
TRYING TO ENFORCE OUR OWN
FEDERAL LAW.
WATCH.
>> THE METHOD FOR BORDER
PROTECTION, STOP REJECTING
ASYLUM-SEEKERS WHO TRY TO
PRESENT THEMSELVES AS A PORT OF
ENTRY.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
YOU KNOW YOU TURN PEOPLE AWAY.
YOU COMPLAIN THEY ARE BREAKING
THE LAW BY ENTERING ILLEGALLY.
YOU ARE BREAKING THE LAW AND YOU
ARE FORCING THEM TO BREAK THE
LAW.
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE CARAVANS.
>> Tucker: SOMETHING YOU
DEFTLY WANT SOMEONE TO CONTROL,
SCREAMING IN A BULLHORN.
THIS IS NOT IMMIGRATION.
IMMIGRATION HAPPENS WITH THE
CONSENT OF THE HOST COUNTRY.
THIS IS HAPPENING BY FORCE
WITHOUT OUR CONSENT.
A GOVERNMENT THAT CARES ABOUT
ITS OWN CITIZENS WOULDN'T ALLOW
IT TO HAPPEN.
BAD THINGS HAPPEN WHEN YOU LEAVE
YOUR HOME AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT.
THE LEFT IS DEMANDING WE LEAVE
OUR DOOR OPEN.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE AMAZING
PEOPLE.
THEY SAY FAR BETTER THAN YOU
ARE, MR. ENTITLED AMERICAN.
THAT'S THE CONVERSATION WITH
HENRIQUE AZEVEDO OF UNIVISION
AND HE MADE THAT POINT.
IF YOU ARE RIGHT UP AGAINST A
COUNTRY TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL
AS PEOPLE ARE SHOOTING EACH
OTHER IN THE NUMBERS YOU JUST
DESCRIBED, WHY WOULDN'T YOU BE
TERRIFIED TO LET THEM IN?
>> I THINK YOU ARE NOT GETTING
THE CRIMINALS.
YOU ARE GETTING THE BEST OF
MEXICO, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WILLING TO WORK 2-3 SHIFTS A
DAY, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS --
B1 HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
>> THE PEOPLE WHO ARE FLEEING
THE VIOLENCE, THAT'S WHAT YOU
ARE GETTING.